no
[Música]
ah
i
yo creo que ustedes mandando un mensaje
a cali estupendo porque en este momento
lo que necesitamos son personas como
ustedes que están dispuestas a innovar a
pensar a tener espacios para poner bien
y no ir a hacer violencia muy bien muy
bien
no sabía que el resumen iba a salir aquí
creo que ya me puedes pedir muchas
gracias
bueno efectivamente el modelo
universitario como lo conocemos hoy data
del siglo 12 eso arrancó pues por allá
en medio del medioevo por cierto cuando
había algo de problemas de conocimiento
y no desarrollamos digamos el desarrollo
pues no desarrollamos la ciencia y
entonces
gracias a los dominicos primero y a
otras comunidades religiosas se empezó a
desarrollar lo que conocemos como
universidad entonces estaban se reunían
los maestros y se reunían los
estudiantes a pensar el tema de cómo
desarrollar profesiones para eso era que
se reunían
es innegable las universidades
pertenecen a un sistema más grande un
sistema que se llama terciario están las
instituciones técnicas las tecnológicas
y en esta conferencia voy a incluir
también los cursos mutsch y las
universidades virtuales y demás porque
lo que vamos a hablar toca para todos
es innegable las ventajas hace poquito
estaba leyendo un artículo y por ejemplo
pues es obvio que la gente que estudia
en una universidad o en un sistema
terciario en general pues tiene acceso a
un mejor trabajo eso es algo esperado
pero también los emprendedores se
desarrollan más fácil porque tienen el
networking conozco a otra persona y
entonces esa persona en algún momento me
puede ayudar y hay un montón de
estadísticas adicionales no la gente que
va a las universidades o al sistema
terciario es un poco más saludable a mí
me falta un poquito pero por ejemplo
fuma menos y son más cívicos te
entienden a votar más
sin embargo todas esas ventajas que hay
del sistema terciario ocurren únicamente
si se obtiene un título únicamente un
poco exagerado pero normalmente se
obtiene si llegas al título si tú no
llegas al título entonces las cosas son
de otro precio
por ejemplo
se afectan las personas que intentaron a
estudiarse y entonces obviamente
financieramente quedas muy golpeada o
por ejemplo tu familia puede tener
también una dificultad ahorita una
estadística sobre eso
entonces la charla tiene que ver primero
con cómo logramos sostener a ese volumen
de personas que están estudiando en las
universidades para que no deserten
porque de lo contrario no se tienen los
beneficios y voy a hablar de otro tema
que también nos toca a todos aquí y es
el tema de la cuarta revolución
industrial y están muy relacionados la
cuarta revolución industrial estamos en
medio de ella ya ya no podemos decir que
va a llegar yo digo ya está es una
revolución como todas las anteriores que
tiene un montón de cosas
interesantísimas por ejemplo en la
aparición de nuevos empleos
por ejemplo el desarrollo de la sociedad
pero esta revolución se organiza por la
conjunción de cuatro fuerzas grandísimas
el internet de las cosas ya los
aparaticos se conectan a internet y
hablan unos con otros la inteligencia
artificial de lo cual yo voy a hablar un
poquito ahorita el cloud computing
y la computación cuántica que por cierto
ya es una realidad ya hoy tú puedes
entrar a una página web y tener acceso a
computadores cuánticos y programar en
computadores cuánticos
es a reunir en esta foto esto es típico
de las industrias incluso aquí en
colombia cuanto humanos vemos ahí
pues ninguno en estos días hoy a una una
entrevista a macri el presidente de
argentina y estaba muy contento creo que
oppenheimer con el que hablaba y estaba
muy contento porque iba a haber una
inversión enorme la argentina de 200 mil
millones de pesos una cosa así
estrambótica estaba muy contento
20 empleos y generas
cuando lleguen al moto será la empresa
más grande del mundo hace 20 años 30
años sólo 30 años tenía 600 mil empleos
generaban 600 mil empleos hoy google es
pero depende del día que uno lea la
prensa porque eso cambia todos los días
pero google es una de las empresas más
grandes del mundo hoy incluso si se
compara financieramente
google tiene 40 mil empleos genera 40
mil empleos en el mundo no más y es más
grande que lo que era general motors es
un momento más importante esta
revolución tiene dos diferencia una
diferencia muy importante contra las
demás revoluciones y esto nos va a
afectar a todos y es que
el tiempo en el cual impacta la sociedad
es muy rápido en la primera revolución
industrial
cuando aparece la electricidad el señor
que iba por las calles prendiendo las
cositas de gas para poder ver en la
calle tuvo 70 años
para entrenarse y cambiar de empleo
pero en esta revolución industrial tú
vas a tener días para entrenarte
entonces esta revolución industrial va a
ser maravillosa al largo plazo va a
generar muchísimo empleo empleos
totalmente novedosas que no nos podemos
imaginar hoy
pero el primer envión va a ser muy duro
porque va a cancelar un mundo de empleos
joven jaime por cierto también para
presenciarlo a él en su libro último
dice referenciando a oxford que el 50%
del empleo se van a perder en muy corto
plazo entonces todo junto a dos cosas
quiere decir que
los que estamos empleados
nos conviene que las universidades
desarrollen modelos donde nos podamos
entrenar
pero también nos conviene que no nos
dejen despertar entonces estamos
hablando de los temas que he juntado los
estudiantes que están en las
universidades que no queremos que
deserten y también los que estamos
empleados que nos vamos a ver afectados
por la revolución industrial la cuarta y
tenemos que entrenarnos rápidamente y
tenemos que lograr los títulos y el
desarrollo y las competencias que
queremos ok
no sé si se ve bien la gráfica
estos son traje algunos de los estudios
mundiales y son pues
por no decir asustadores venía en eeuu
ese estudio de hace poquitos años
el 40% de las personas que entran a este
sistema universitario nunca se gradúan
nunca se gradúan del sistema
universitario pero lo mismo pasa en
europa miren ss a toda europa es el 43%
eso eso es el promedio de los países
europeos ahí gracias a dios y por
desgracia también peores datos por
ejemplo en francia el primer año en
muchas de las universidades públicas hay
una universidad pública pero se divide
puede ser en números parís 1 parís 2
parís 3 en el primer año puede desertar
el 70% de los estudiantes en el primer
año y lo mismo pasa en asia ese dato que
puse ahí desde asia completó un estudio
de la unesco
el mejor país de asia es corea del norte
con el sur perdón con una excepción del
49% de cada dos personas una de ser una
jamás se gradúa imagínense el resto de
países asiáticos y están muy
desarrollados en colombia pues como ven
la cosa no es que sea muy buena tampoco
ese es un reporte un estudio del banco
mundial del año pasado del 2018
el 50% de los estudiantes no se gradúan
del 48 y si le preguntan a duke es el 46
depende de donde uno
consulte
pero en colombia pasa otro fenómeno muy
grave y es que somos en latinoamérica el
país con la mayor relación costo
educativo pib eso significa que cuando
alguien de ser está en colombia es más
costoso que en cualquier otro país
traje también las estadísticas de los
cursos virtuales masivos online
lastimosamente esa estadística distinta
en las universidades es el que entra en
la universidad y exige graduar pero esta
es el que se registra en un curso
y vamos a terminar el curso esas
defecciones del 95% entonces si por aca
escampa pues sí porque llueve para dar
un scan para algo hay que hacer
ok
el tema de excepción impacta a muchas
personas ya lo dije a la persona que
debe serlo porque emocionalmente queda
golpeado financieramente que ha golpeado
a la familia a la cual pertenece a esa
persona miren este dato en colombia un
tercio de los estudiantes que entran al
sistema educativo universitario viene de
familias que es la primera vez que
alguien va a la universidad
eso quiere decir que si una persona está
desierta el golpe para la familia puede
ser enorme
también se impactan las universidades
y todos me imagino lo sabemos la silla
vacía los cursos de los primeros años
enormes los cursos de los últimos años
chiquititos tremendamente costosos
y qué pasa si esos cursos son muy
costosos pues la universidad tiene que
subir la matrícula
tiene que compensar eso y si sube la
matrícula se vuelve más elitista menos
gente puede acceder a ella entonces por
todo lado pues al golpe este es un
reporte del ministerio de educación
nacional de hace no sé tales cuatro años
en este reporte
el ministerio saca la lista de todas las
posibles causas que explican la
deserción la persona desertó porque se
quedó sin plata porque su papá se quedó
sin empleo y usted y la persona no pudo
pagar o la persona desertó porque no
tuvo empatía con la universidad llegó a
la universidad y no se sintió bien con
sus compañeros
o de ser todo porque se enfermó o porque
se encontró con profesores con los
cuales no cuadraba
entonces
el tema de la excepción es supremamente
estudiado si usted va una biblioteca va
a haber libros y libros y libros del
tema de la deserción y las universidades
y como les digo los demás instituciones
también pues han hecho mucho para tratar
de reducirla por ejemplo
la persona no sabe estudiar no tiene
metodologías no tiene pedagogía no sabe
cómo hacerlo entonces las universidades
crearon centros pedagógicos donde uno va
y le ayudan a
a saber cómo cómo estudiar o por ejemplo
no tengo dinero entonces las
universidades crearon centros de ayuda
financiera que estuvo allá y te dan
puedes aplicar una beca a un descuento a
pagos por cuotas e incluso hoy ya a
pagos a largo plazo esto también ya se
consigue te viene la pregunta del millón
si es un problema tan grave si es un
problema que lleva mucho tiempo y las
universidades están preocupadas y en
general todo el sistema terciario en
reducirlo y está tan estudiado
porque no lo resolvemos
y no se resuelve en nuestro concepto en
el grupo en que yo trabajo
por el timing
el timing
cuando una universidad se da cuenta que
el muchacho no tenía métodos de estudio
cuando
cuando está en prueba
y ahí ya es grave el muchacho en prueba
ya está pensando irse
cuando le da ayuda financiera
cuando ya dejó de pagar y ya
posiblemente ahí ya dijo no no tenemos
cómo pagar mejor m hoy el icex que me
busque porque no me va a encontrar
pero la realidad del timing está
equivocado
entonces eso fue lo que hicimos nosotros
en el grupo nuestro nos concentramos en
ese problema como lo grabamos y eso fue
lo que hicimos desarrollamos un modelo
basado en machine learning
ojo porque ahora les voy a hacer un
examen entonces pongan atención
ese modelo de machine learning lo que
hace es precisamente reconocer a tiempo
que estudiante tiene una alta
probabilidad de acertar eso lo que hace
y lo calcula constantemente no es raro
todo estamos expuestos a machine
learning
y traje varios ejemplos ma jin learn es
un área de inteligencia artificial que
pertenece a las ciencias de la
computación
todo el día interactuamos con bayern y
cuando tú le hablas a tu celular pues
ahí está funcionando un algoritmo de
machine learning cuando te reconocieron
en facebook en la fiesta que tú no
querías que te reconocieran también aquí
el apuesto fotomulta
a medida que adivine que fue fue machine
learning cuando tú entras a netflix y te
sale unas películas y luego ves a tu
mamá y le salen las películas más
chéveres porque a ella le salen unas
camino es alma schindler ning machine
learning lo que busca es patrones ese es
el truco patrones traje aprendizaje
supervisado porque es una técnica que
voy a explicar ahorita básicamente se le
muestran a esos algoritmos ejemplos
positivos y negativos en el caso de
decepción un muchacho que sí es cierto
un muchacho que no es cierto una niña
que sí es cierto una niña que no es
cierto y así sucesivamente y él
encuentra patrones yo no le
retroalimenta entonces así es como
funciona está listo para el examen
bueno
que ven ahí
levanten la mano los que ven algo
este público es inteligentísimo levanten
la mano los que no no me tiran
ya los demás y ya todo el mundo así
estamos todos ya ahora si todos estamos
con el perrito el dálmata te puedo sacar
aquí adelante y tú me di señales entre
otros
bueno yo para tranquilidad todo yo lo
señale
estamos listos estamos listos bueno
ahora dígame que ve ahí
lo que vale
a muy bien el dálmata al revés también
se lo señale por qué
pero la pregunta del millón es cómo hizo
su cerebro para reconocer el segundo al
matar si usted nunca había visto esa
foto eso se lo y les cuento un secreto
está esta foto se consigue en internet
ahí está la referencia
y así pasan 20 años el día que usted vea
esta foto va a reconocer al perro así de
poderosos son los patrones y eso fue lo
que hicimos nosotros en nuestro grupo
así es como se hace primero reconoce el
problema quiero crear un modelo que
permita reconocer estudiantes que van a
desertar
luego sacas las hipótesis que lo
explican y encuentra los datos que
sustentan esa hipótesis
prepara los datos modelos modelar es
esos datos y enfrentarnos a muchos
algoritmos de machine learning no se
enfrentan a uno a muchos y el que mejor
de sí te funciona es el que lleva esa
producción porque como nos fue a
nosotros pues usamos 7000 variables y
ahí el término big data porque 7000
variables pues es fácil
nosotros miramos cada profesor con el
cual cada estudiante paso por cada
asignatura como fue valor ese profesor
que estudios tenía
con qué compañeros trabajo cuántos
conocía cuántos no es muy fácil de siete
mil variables y hemos llegado a niveles
de precisión del 92 por ciento tema
poder ha sido el ejemplo
cuando esa curva rojita
es una diagonal recta
es que tu algoritmo es tan bueno como
adivinar con una moneda ok este muchacho
de ser tan cara de ser tan este no ese
sería el poder si la línea fuera recta
roja como ven está acumulada salsa'
comba hacia hacia arriba cierto tendré
más comba da más fuerte ese algoritmo
por eso nuestros algoritmos están
funcionando bastante bien ok de cada 100
estudiantes en el caso general civil a
92 sabemos si va a desertar o no y
podemos tomar acciones para corregirlo y
yo pensé que ya ahí ya ya teníamos que
entregarles a los psicólogos y listo
vamos a pasar a otro problema y nos
llevamos la sorpresa del siglo
porque los psicólogos nos preguntaron
esto bueno esto lo que les mostramos a
los consejeros les decimos dónde está la
decepción en cada semestre pero miren
que hay mucha deserción lo rojito es un
muchacho con alta probabilidad de
acertar en los primeros semestres pero
también en los últimos
chistoso no
no termino la tesis exactamente hay
decepción en punta y punta depende la
carrera no hay ingeniería sistemas por
ejemplo es muy difícil conseguir
estudiantes entre estos benditos llegan
a octavo la empresa les contrata y se
olvidaron del tema porque ella también
pero el resto de las carreras es más
complicado derecho por ejemplo y creo
que este derecho el problema es la
presentada algo que son los exámenes d
preparatorios esa vaina la muertos
pero también lo mostramos persona por
persona el consejero puede mirar esta
persona y decir
se aumentó la probabilidad de acertar
algo tenemos que hacerle algo
curiosamente todo el mundo nos pregunta
lo mismo pero cuál es la variable
y el problema de la excepción es un
problema complejo no es un problema
lineal pero vamos a ver que es un
problema lineal suponga que usted quiere
predecir va a cara al tablero
llega a partir de equis y le dan estos
ejemplos no veo una línea y mal que bien
de la línea entonces yo uso un modelo
lineal pero yo para aproximar fácil por
ejemplo ahí estoy tratando de predecir
una variable y la diferencia entre la
realidad y lo que el modelo dice pues es
una cualquiera mal vayas que es el error
estamos pero si los datos no son
lineales y en deserción no son lineales
pues si yo trato de usar un modelo
lineal es decir dígame cuál es la
variable que más pesa pues el error es
altísimo estamos trabajando ahora y esa
es la última cosa que va a ser en la
conferencia necesitamos ayuda porque
aquí entramos ya en terreno de los
psicólogos y es ayudar a armar el
protocolo que se tiene que usar luego
que ya existe una máquina que es capaz
de predecir con altísima certeza quién
va a acertar y quién no bueno muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]